[Musique]
avez-vous des lacunes
est ce que vous êtes fort pour tout ce
qui est calcul mais vous êtes hull pour
tous qui orthographe puisque vous êtes
fort pour tous cartographe mais vous
êtes nuls pour tous qui calcule moi je
m'en sors assez bien dans les deux mais
j'ai énormément de lacunes en géographie
et oui et pourquoi mais c'est ça je me
souviens très bien c'est qu'on
d'histoire en 4e 3e où il fallait
apprendre les cartes du monde voilà il
est plein de cartes à prendre lucas il a
fait quoi et d'apprendre les car il a
joué son fait qu'à la belle 72 sur dofus
et la russie sur n'en contrôle ça me
passionnait pas du tout la géographie et
je n'ai jamais fait l'effort d'aller sur
une carte du monde et d'apprendre où il
ya quel pays je connais un peu la base
portugal espagne france allemagne
angleterre ça va mais y'a plein de pays
que je place pas du tout aux bons
endroits et aujourd'hui on va jouer un
jeu qui va mettre à l'épreuve mon skin
négatif en géographie s'appelle marzouk
with one comme et le but extrêmement
simple on va avoir un plan aérien une
ville assez zoomer il faut deviner
quelle capitale d'europe c'est et si tu
ne trouves pas car toi aussi tu joues à
dofus et d'aller en cours d'histoire et
ben il ya un bouton pour dézoomer un peu
l'image et avoir plus d'éléments dessus
du coup c'est plus facile pour deviner
ce que c'est et tu peux dézoomer jusqu'à
voir la carte du monde voilà plusieurs
quiz de dispo il ya les grandes villes
aux us mais c'en est nul les parque
nacional je t'en parle même pas les lacs
aux états unis mais y'a les capitales
européennes
et c'est cela qui nous intéresse qu elle
est capitale de villes d'europe c'est au
high à un peu d'eau il faut que le doute
il faut que le doute parce que les
villes où il ya énormément d'autres mots
c'est une capitale dont on sait à peu
près de venise turin venise peine
capitale
y en a dans le ciboulot on va désormais
un peu auquel la mer direct via que la
mer et si lé petit bateau des riches ici
on peut les voir bien sûr ses doigts et
espagne ça non et cela ne ressemble pas
à ça mais qu'est-ce qui en bord de mer
et qui peut ressembler ce geab sont que
c'est l'angleterre mec je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai l'impression que si
l'angleterre est marquée londres mec
c'était règles j'habite en islande
non mais on est sérieux et bien sûr je
serai situer cette ville sur une carte
reykjavík capitale de l'islande mais
ouais y avait plein de verdure partout
là j'aurais dû deviner
et on se parle c'était pas facile non
plus un pass mito savoir sur une map
c'est là à celle à l'islande
mais je croyais que c'était genre entre
le royaume uni et la norvège mais je
suis fier c'est un truc de ouf j'ai
honte mais un truc de malade j'ai envie
de me flinguer
bon c'est pas ces choses qui arrivent
suivant on va s'installer ou des toits
comme ça ça a déjà la météo lie à la
chaleur qui tape un jeu peut la sentir
d'ici ouf c'est très coloré au niveau
des thouars et lumineux
mouais ici là il ya un mec en débardeur
ça monte qui fait au moins 40 35 40
degrés 35 40 degrés c'est quoi ces
espagne au portugal
bon on fait plaisir nos amis portugais
ou lérins mais franchement je sais que
là vous me dites non mais il fait exprès
et tout c'est une grosse mer franchement
je fais pas exprès je me confie à vous
c'est mon gros gros gros gros point
faible à géo situer les endroits
connaître les capitales la femme a eu du
mal quand même
lisbonne alors lisbonne est ce que c'est
ça c'est tout de même pas ça oui ok bon
sévère à laisser l'islande non sévère
mais c'est raisonnable juste pas mal
d'arrêts ce que je note surtout c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup de dollars d ici un
canal ici un autre canal
ici un autre canal il y en a absolument
partout il ya beaucoup de ton aussi ça
me fait penser à amsterdam un peu d'air
je suis allé à mme samia pas très
longtemps pas pour faire ce que vous
pensez que j'étais étonné de la ville
c'est super beau jeu mais je n'ai pas ça
aussi bossé magnifique si je crois
qu'elle musée de la [ __ ] rigoler mais
c'est vraiment viser que j'ai visités là
bas et c'était vraiment nul n'y allez
pas surtout pas assez nul à chier mais
bon tu vas amsterdam tu vois musée de la
bible ça te fait rire tu vas voilà bon
bref c'est l'histoire amsterdam vrai ou
faux voilà le mec était l'oml 130 sur
dofus il connaissait pas ses cartes mais
mon poids que sept ans plus tard on est
bien alors il ya des parcs immense
partout qu'est ce que ça peut être là le
mexique on est un peu de matos évidence
et le parc national du kabuki ce temps
c'est marrant parce que rien qu'avec la
couleur de lee majors et des toits on
arrive à savoir s'il faisait beau ou pas
la température et du coup vous devinez
un peu la zone géographique voilà ou
alors c'est mon esprit un peu tordu qui
développe cette technique secrète
attends je zoome un peu poète sûreté ya
encore un parc là non c'est pas qu'en
suède ça attends ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta en suède en plus d'un capital
c'est [ __ ] y'a dice la base ce qui
développe bf c'est un métier sur le bout
de la langue
mais que j'ai sur le bout de la langue
aux hommes un mec dans la ok c'est
stockholm stockholm ses marques et je
vais courir blessure bout la langue il n
a jamais un café ça c'est bizarre tu
l'as tu prends idée tu l'ifa désabonner
pas s'il vous plaît mais franchement
quand j'avais 12 ans et je joue à dofus
je pensais déjà cette blague aujourd'hui
j'ai enfin osé la faire cesser une sorte
de rêve qui se réalise et merci à tous
c'était très très gênant alors c'est
stockholm j'ai un sentiment qui me dit
c'est ce qu'a bien joué c'est athènes en
grèce mais je suis tellement con mais
ch'est pas qu'il y avait des parcs comme
ça immense en grèce je savais pas que la
grèce s'était alors on va pas abuser non
mais tranquille tranquille
oui parce qu'elle veut quand même bon
vin nouveau alors la température on est
sur un petit un petit 18° faut que des
sommes pareilles un très grand parc ici
ça ressemble trop à ce qu'on avait avant
ici est juste un énorme flop ici un
stade à tence pas paris quand même
n'importe quoi à paris a pas du tout
autant derby si clairement c'est pas
pareil j'ai envie de croire à berlin ou
à stockholm matin j'ai désormais encore
je suis pas sûr qu'il a tellement
d'heures beaucoup mais c'est clairement
pas pareil mais c'est un peu paumé
attend encore un peu mais au nom mais là
non mes mecs c'est au milieu de nulle
part mon pote caisse commune au nul par
un pays d'europe dont la capitale au
milieu de nulle part' pire carte sa pire
car je saigne des yeux allez salut boisé
et consulter la page de fais-moi cliquez
ici non mais c'est rare est ok mais non
mais [ __ ] mais si c'est dur de trouver
une carte sur google à teamnor ou essai
oslo mec c'est sûr c'est sûr yard up
oslo fna et prague et en mai mais
franchement vous avez deviné en vrai
vous aviez deviné c'est ce sens qu'à
conserver aujourd'hui le bout
pragmatique je vous raconte qu'ils ont
été effacés bon on vient de trouver la
ville de prague
vous connaissez je suis dit tu perds le
plus gros de youtube et je fais des jeux
de mots vraiment exceptionnel je voulais
donc dire à alain n'a pas trouvé prague
vendent et très pragmatique ou un truc
du genre mais pour que cette blague se
passe bien je voulais être sûr à 100% du
sens du mot pragmatique je suis donc
aller sur un site qui aide à la
définition et je me suis tapé un spam
audio si cette histoire ça intéressait
n'hésite pas à m'envoyer un nude ça me
fera plaisir ou ne fait rien il pète pas
passer à autre chose
des mythes qu'est-ce que ça peut bien un
peu d'armes c'est pas pareil et une
grande roue là vous l'avez [ __ ] au la
grande roue mais qu'elle m'a fait kiffer
et celle en donne bien sûr
[Musique]
c'est un très beau jour c'était très
très ce qu'il est j'ai trouvé l'un grâce
à la london eye nom de la grande roue si
vous saviez pas voilà on apprend des
choses que les ce2 savent déjà mais bon
on sent bien franchement avec de l'eau
comme ça encore est-ce que c'est pas
stockholm non mais que j'ai pas sorti ce
morceau de papier de ma bouche pour rien
qu'il ait servi à quelque chose non non
non c'est parce qu il ya un parc mon
pote il est immense rolla rolla pardon
la série outre ailleurs benjamin succès
en allemagne mexes en allemagne c'est
berlin peut-être vous ne comprenez pas
ma joie je la comprends moi même qu'à
moitié
c'est juste que je suis profondément nul
en géo et là j'arrive à deviner ça fait
super plaisir ce jeu a été inventé pour
te rassurer quand tu pue la merde en géo
clairement clairement le mec à côté
vieux steria quitter dans mcgill sur
dofus qui jouent au meilleur que moi il
a pris sa vengeance sur la vie en face
alors why and andrew là
[Musique]
bonsoir messieurs aujourd'hui vous savez
ce qu'on va faire on va c'est faux on ne
tombe pas les vidéos à la chaîne comme
ça chez squeeze industria et la malaisie
d'ici à la fin de cette vidéo sur maps
zoom quiz point corps n'était pas lesté
elle vous a plu je vous rassure il n'y a
pas que ce quiz la ja bas vous l'avez vu
au début la vidéo il ya le quiz pour
trouver les lacs les grandes vues des us
et ses jeux passion peut en créer soi
même ce serait cool brand tout cas
n'hésitez pas à jouer à ce jeu c'est
très amusant pour renforcer un peu votre
skill en géographie je suis très content
de ma prestation mais parce qu'elle
était tout simplement excellent à la
base une prochaine vidéo
allez bon vent à la lamelle aller jouer
là et à bientôt c'est que vous foutez
quoi encore c'est fini ses terres il
faut cliquer dans une des vidéos la
suggestion il sait se terminer à la
bientôt